Margot Robbie Queen Godzilla minus one
oh what a movie right yeah movie was
epic I watched it with one of my best
friends and he instantly looked at me
and was like that's a you
movie we're back on the street asking
folks what movie did you love the most
last year comment right now and let us
know your favorite movie of 2023 let's
see what the folks had to say I say
Barbie Barbie hands down Barbie I did
love Barbie it was great what was it
about Barbie that you loved I loved
absolutely everything about that movie
Ryan Goslin as Ken oh my God incredible
Margot Robbie Queen every little thing
was perfect and I have not laughed that
hard at a movie in so long it made me
laugh it actually made me cry too and
come on I'm just Ken it's the best song
out there have you ever picked up an
acoustic guitar and sang Matchbox 20 to
impress a girl I have not cuz I'm
terrible with
instruments Jen I would say the
Renaissance movie it's not really a
movie it's like like a concert oh like
like a special event where they had like
classical music oh OU the Beyonce movie
oh yeah that that totally counts
Godzilla minus one think Godzilla minus
one yeah W what a movie right yeah movie
was epic just really like the characters
how they dived in deep into especially
the main character I don't want to give
any spoilers but it was really good and
also Godzilla shows up
yes I'm going to say trans performers
that was a really good movie like a lot
of action a lot of you know Adventures
Oppenheimer for sure oh right it was a
trip it was like like in a good way you
know I never really didn't anticipate
the the whole twist between Robert
Downey Jr so I was like yo that's crazy
yeah B was afraid it was a great movie
extremely long it was wild I love Ari
Aster he's three for three in my book
killers of the flower Moon close second
so you like long movies is what I'm
gathering that's so untrue typically but
those two tickled my uh fancy I would
say controversial opinion saltburn I
love you I love you seriously thank you
so much I loved it um I watched it with
one of my best friends and he instantly
looked at me and was like that's a ovie
like it was like 2 seconds over with and
he just looked at me and was like yeah
that makes sense that you like that
there's like mystery there's like
there's murder there's like beautiful
shot and that camera they just leave
that thing running sometimes it's great
it's great I love feeling uncomfortable
on a shot it's wonderful oh how
wonderful
let's look forward a little bit let's go
to 2024 what's the movie that you're
most excited to check out this coming
year oh that's easy Dune part two I need
that movie in my veins need it I'm
excited man I the first one was amazing
if the second one lives up to it I'm I'm
going to be blown away I've been
watching the trailers all day and all
night just cuz it's so beautiful and I
cannot wait to just be immersed into
that movie there's a new movie coming
out that has like a viral marketing
campaign that I just heard about that
looks scary I don't think anybody knows
the title of it yet they're just like
using hieroglyphics to advertise the
movie the movie you're most looking
forward to uh this year is working title
I think I'm going to get corrected if
anybody ever sees this and and comment
let us know what movie we're talking
about Kung Fu Panda 4 for sure yeah
they're always good movies right
absolutely Kung Fu Panda or the new
Garfield Garfield Garfield yeah okay but
Garfield doesn't have the best track
record on the big screen doesn't we
watched the old one yesterday and he was
like what is this but the new one looks
really really cute Kingdom of the Planet
of the Apes remains to be seen if an
astronaut lands in this future it's the
real future it's not the near
future what a wonderful day well that's
all the time we have here on on the
street make sure you the movie is
allegedly called long
legs long legs long legs thank you Kevin
inside out too I'm really excited to see
my crippling anxiety on a screen I'm so
excited it's not going to damage me
emotionally at all finally you get to
see you on the big screen Deadpool is
definitely going to be something that
I'm looking forward to you get you get
everything in one movie right there yeah
yeah yeah yeah and and Wolverine is in
this one okay yes I'm definitely in all
in the suit looks really cool you know
he's going back to X-Men 97 type of look
who knows what who else is going to be
on in on that right could have a lot of
cameos very stoked for that we saw Logan
a couple of times in theaters so we see
movies multiple times never heard of
them Godzilla versus Kong yeah but now
they're teaming up you cool with that I
don't know yet I'll see how that plays
out not really I kind of like the good
guys and bad guys stay separate you know
so who's the good guy in Godzilla versus
Kong I'm going always go with Kong cuz
he's just great that's the correct
answer lot of good answers for the best
movie of 2023 now it's your turn comment
let us know what was your favorite flick
of last year and make sure you subscribe
right here at Rotten Tomatoes thanks for
checking this vid out head over to
rotten tomatoes.com for everything in
the world of movies TV and in between
you sure you don't want the Taco Bell
Bell in the background ideally not thank
you so much I really appreciate that's
okay that's okay nervous I sweat because
I like sweating I'm I'm very harmless I
promise